this week on world stories Philippines
the firebrand takes office Israel
Ramadan noise but we begin in Britain
the vote to leave the European Union is
causing fine residents to question their
future on the island like in this
example from London the vote for brexit
was sobering news for many but it was
especially bitter for Steve from Ireland
and Benedict from Germany they set up a
craft brewery in London a year ago now
the referendum result has them worried
there's four directors in this company
for Pete founders who started it irish
german and two Swedes so that's the
first level of uncertainty is our future
here second level is this four
ingredients and beer we use English
water London water London English malt
hops come from everywhere and then our
yeast is it's pretty safe to but it is
in terms of de use Brussels oh it's from
both of course it is course it is all
right so we've got two out of two out of
four ingredients we're good for two
we're good for 280 for Steve and
Benedict are typical of the many young
Londoners who believe brexit can only be
bad for their future many of those young
voters demonstrated outside parliament
at the weekend to bend their anger at a
decision they say was not theirs we're
the generation that's going to be
completely screwed over by the recession
so I don't really see why the older
generations you've already had their
jobs and have their houses how will how
women to get on with it now even I
really we should have put a bit of 14 to
do who we just might affect you know
we're the ones who I hope you're going
to have to live with this to 70 years
it's not it's not those are going to
have to live with it and it's gonna
almost impossible to rectify now it's
gone through some just a sad real more
sad than annoyed really
Steve and Benedict are questioning their
plans for the future they were planning
to invest in their brewing business and
hoped eventually to sell their craft
beers on the Europe in the market but
they've now put that plan on hold
in the Philippines president Roderick a
tu ta has declared war on crime though
not without critics this approach
continues to prove popular not least in
the city of Davao where he was until
recently the mayor meet Rodrigo Duterte
the new president of the Philippines his
trademark a relentless crusade against
drugs and crime he acquired his
reputation here in davao in his 22 years
as mayor he's managed to transform the
city from one of the most notorious for
crime kidnappings and drugs into one of
the safest in the whole country many
people in Davao admire him for that I
know him for a long time as a leader a
great leader he do what he says and he
mean he do what he says and he take
action for what he planned he made that
vow so nice even of people follow rules
regulations we need a strong leader to
manage to the whole Philippines because
it's a total wreck but security and
cleanliness aren't the only things
Rodrigo Duterte brought to the valve in
his time as name while the tortoise
track record as mayor seems compelling
it is some of the radical methods he
advocates that has put him in the
spotlight repeatedly he has endorsed
extrajudicial killings of petty
criminals using vigilante death squads
more than 1,400 people have reportedly
been assassinated in the Devourer region
since the late 1990s many here believe
de terre des is responsible for at least
some of these killings but so far
investigators haven't been able to
establish a single case against him the
problem has always been the absence of
witnesses who were willing to cooperate
in the inquiries or one beach one would
be out of fear a feeling one knows all
too well one is not his real name and he
doesn't want to be recognized as a vocal
critic of detector and his methods he's
been receiving death threats
the mayor's supporters we've heard about
even kids getting mistaken for drug
pushers and getting killed and we also
know about journalists who've been
killed you've been very vocal against
the targa there's this low hum of
anxiety if my enemy you know accuses me
of being a criminal then I can get
easily killed but people don't want to
talk about it and if you criticize it
there that you you'll get harassed
Rodrigo Duterte Savior or monster
filipinos appear to be of two minds but
one thing is certain even though his
term in office is just starting he's
already the most controversial president
the philippines have had in at least
three decades
Kenya leads Africa when it comes to
internet access but life's not easy for
bloggers the bloggers association of
Kenya has been trying to empower online
commentators for Ollie she Timmy
blogging is not just a hobby he's been
doing it full time for five years the
activist wants the media to be more
effective in serving the public he sees
this as a prerequisite for good
governance and an informed citizenry his
blogs are well established and respected
but he faces some obstacles the biggest
challenge for me is the the perception
that bloggers are paid in Kenya or that
especially Google's are paid to defame
people to write wrong things about about
about people when he's not working from
home he meets up with fellow bloggers
there are around 15,000 of them in Kenya
most of whom are in Nairobi only a few
are members of the bloggers Association
of Kenya or bake they meet at I hub the
unofficial headquarters of Kenya's tech
movement app developers or startup
supporters like my lab work here the
company offers baked members workspace
and internet service five years ago a
small group of Internet activists formed
the Association its membership of 2,500
is growing
founding member jamesu amitha is aware
of the potential in Kenya's blogger
community members gather occasionally to
discuss the funds they need to offer
regular training for bloggers
communities across the country like to
see more one more people and especially
outside of Nairobi so in essence they
are not only telling their story they're
not only telling the world what
happening in that specific country but
they also making money for me and
employing other people they say that
each training experience strengthens the
bloggers network and they come away with
practical tips how to conduct research
how to use social media platforms and
how to write in a style suited to the
commercial use of blogs for several
years bake has been giving blog awards
it's the entertainment technology or
fashion blogs that usually win it's less
glamorous for political bloggers in the
last two years following the passage of
laws restricting media freedom the
number of bloggers arrested has
increased bake offers its members legal
advice sometimes to non-members to la
mothe i says that individuals free
expression online can lead to a freer
Society
kenya's blogger community is walking a
kind of tightrope between glamour and
research but the founders of the bake
Association would like to see more
people taking part in Kenya's social
development for them the blog awards are
just the beginning
our last report is from Israel in
Jerusalem during the holy month of
Ramadan cannon blasts marked the
beginning and the end of the day's fast
for the Muslim community the Sun is
setting over Jerusalem many Palestinians
hurried to buy groceries on their way
home rajasthan duka makes his way up to
the cemetery across from the old town
he's here to fire the Ramadan cannon
every evening it's the signal for
Muslims that their day of fasting is
over easier said than done after a 15
hour fast so I belong on Harpo Ian it's
difficult the days are long and this
year Ramadan happens to fall during the
longest days of the year well not good
but in the end you feel good about
yourself because you were fulfilling
your duty to god I'm thought there was
like that cuz ya'll be like that San
duka fires the cannon to mark the
beginning of the Ramadan fast in the
morning and the end in the evening it's
a ritual that's been passed on from
father to son within the same family for
over 120 years it is part of our
tradition to this day most people in the
old town do not break the fast until
they hear the sound of the cannon fire
even if they hear the prayers from the
mosque and the loudspeakers they still
wait for the cannon unless walls with
the red phone the cannon itself is a
holdover from the time when Jordan ruled
East Jerusalem it has not been used for
military purposes for a long time today
under Israeli rule the explosives are
brought to the cemetery by two Israeli
security agents San duka is not allowed
to handle explosives without supervision
even if it is just a sound bomb ignited
via remote control the whole time
economy time should we transport the
explosives in a special car then we
secure the location so that enemy
elements don't have access to the site
that is the reason for this procedure
Naomi my name's Erica will come and of
course the most important task is firing
the cannon
at the right time after all thousands
depend on it the mom at the al-aksa
mosque tells him when to fire via mobile
phone it's a far cry from the way his
grandfather did it go people bekhabi
someone was standing in the other side
of the wall to the old town he was given
a sign from someone else at the Temple
Mount my grandfather would then get a
signal via green flag that he should
blast the cannon died and then it's time
at exactly seven forty eight pm San duka
triggers the shot with his remote
control raja sen duka makes his way home
to his iftar meal tomorrow morning at
four he has to be back to announce the
start of another day of fasting
you